box I think that's probably the best way
to because you uh otherwise would have
to sign out and sign back in so if you
could just in the chat box of some place
indicates your name your full name and
your CCA we'll make sure that you get
recorded well in our presentation today
we want to cover three main topics the
first will be evaluating plant stands
followed by weed identification control
by Kirk howt he's uh in the department
of plant science NSU and the final
speaker will be Blake
vandor uh with Ducks Unlimited we'll
talk about disease and nitrogen
management I think after uh Kirk's um
presentation we'll certainly take time
for him to answer some questions he'll
have to leave um if I finish in good
time I might take a few questions on my
section but uh please feel free to hold
questions to the end as well uh we'll
take whatever time needs we do plan to
finish in general terms after an
hour so I'm Joel Ransom extension
Agonist for serial crops my uh part of
my presentation I want to talk about
evaluating plant stands and as you all
know having a good stand in the spring
is key to a productive winter wheat crop
and I've got a glow graph there that
shows the relationship of percent winner
survival and yield and so ultimately we
want to have a reasonable plant stand so
we can work with the question is how
much do we really
need and what are some of factors that
are going to affect survival and I think
this is one of the reasons we want to
talk about this today is because uh we
did make we did start uh our winter
wheek crop last fall in pretty poor
conditions but the factors that are
going to impact the amount of winter
survival are going to be the environment
um we have little or no control over
that temperature at the crown is
probably the most definitive of
environmental factors that we're going
to talk about the second would be the
state of
hardening uh which is a time of year
we'll talk a little more detail about
that the briy
S and the size and bigger of the plant
and the fall so these will be the four
main factors that are going to be uh
influencing the amount of winter
survival that we
have and if we look at the the general
graph that was indic to what
temperatures our plants can tolerate
cold you can see this top graph uh
is some data from Kansas State we see
that we start uh as the plant is
emerging it is not able to tolerate cold
it's kind of like spring weed in that
state and as we go through a period of
cold it will harden off and it gets to
the point where it will be able to
withstand cold temperature down to about
10° fah minus 10° fah
and it will persist in that level of
winter hardiness uh until about February
and at that point the reserves uh start
to diminish and it becomes more
susceptible to coal and we see that as
we move into to much uh where we are now
the ability to withstand cold is is
significantly reduced and it's not
uncommon to have plant stands that had
made it through the winter up to this
point actually be lost when you have go
through a cycle of treason and thigh and
you can see that there's a pretty wide
band of of uh of temperatures that can
be tolerated it really depends on the of
plant the the reserves in the plant the
variety of its own and the kinds of
fluctuation of temperature so it's
pretty hard to predict precisely what
kind of you know
uh what what the plant is going to be
able to to
withstand let me just uh review with you
some data from last year this was a
winter survival model that was put up in
Canada just one to they don't actually
get to see the mouse come through there
okay so if you want that's okay you want
in
here
and and that Arrow will move
around all right so last year sorry
about that little uh intervention it was
a hopefully a use one I was having all
kinds of fun with my cointer and you
weren't seeing it but last year we did
have a winter of wheat survival model
was very descriptive in in kind of
showing how the winter wheat plant uh
tolerates cold and uh and depending on
the variety you can see that like Falcon
and and seator were able to tolerate
just about minus four Fahrenheit and as
you get further into the spring
uh you can see that there were cases
where we actually had winter kill as a
result of plant being less winter hardy
and and temperature being too cold for
it to
survive we look briefly at where we're
at here this is some data that John
nosky has been recording and the top
this top graph shows the winter Golden
Valley and U if we look at the
uh
[Music]
the soil temperatures under a short
stubble we can see that certainly the
temperatures are less haven't captured
as much snow but in general I would say
that those temperatures none of them are
below what we would say as a critical
Lev level for winter winter kill we go
to Cass County the the bottom graph you
can see that we have had some uh
temperatures so temperatures I think
these are about 1 inch depth where our
Crown would likely be down 10 degrees
but again probably because of the snow
cover we've had that our temperatures at
least in these areas haven't been
excessively low so we have to be too
concerned about winter kill
yet um I talked about variety being
important and this is these are some
data I collected in 2003 and four that I
haven't been able to replicate it was a
perfect year for having some we and uh
looking at the soybean residue you can
see that our variey coming from More
Southern locations we we have a very
high level of mortality uh whereas uh
with a little bit of snow cover under
the seats we residue all of our
varieties were able to
tolerate winter and so variety choice is
really critical and I know we've
introduced a lot of Southern kind of
winter wheat varieties in into our
system and so this might be a year um
where we see some of those failing
because of the lay planting and other
factors where in the last couple years
we've had really good survival because
of the snow cover and other
things I mentioned the size of the plant
going into the fall can have an impact
on the winter hardiness and here's just
an example of uh you know very late
planted small plants very few reserves
it's going to have less ability to
tolerate prolong Cal than this plant up
here and and you can actually plant too
early and have too big a plant generally
we don't have that problem in North
Dakota very often because by the time
you get in and plant that recommended
date you don't get a plant that's much
bigger than kind of that what that first
one looks like so I think this is one of
the issues we're a little concerned
about we had very late emergence because
we planted late got the rains didn't
come until much later than normal and
and so um we probably have the plant
that just kind of set set there and
very where got to
start so let's talk about what
constitutes a reasonable stand uh you
want to go out and count several areas
um uh probably I've mentioned two foot
length probably 5 foot would be more uh
realistic and you want to do it in
representative areas of the field you
may have some parts of the field where
you have big gaps and you w't count
those differently than say uh other more
normal Fields you want to evaluate for
Vigor and we have a kind of a general
recommendation that we can
tolerate plant stands down to as low as
five plants per foot I mean that's
probably on our lower end for winter
weat if you compare that to Sprint you
can see that we can tolerate about half
the stand that we can with winter wheat
or with spring
wheat um here's just some data uh
showing you uh that bottom graph would
be coming from Mandan that you really
start to see a yield reduction when the
plant stand is below probably seven or
eight
but we probably are able to to maintain
yield sufficient to make it profitable
to keep that stand if even when we're in
that CL plants per square foot
range um this is some data that I showed
you previously showing you the
relationship between yield and plant
stand and here you know we had down as
low as
20%
survival this would have been kind of a
objective subjective
evaluation uh that we were getting up to
60 bushes which would indicate that
you'd probably want to hang on to that
um some other data this is put together
by Steve dorak looking at uh some of the
you know a range of of varieties over a
number of years uh and you can see that
again probably about that 30 to 40% uh
stand in the spring is going to be a
critical level uh where you want to keep
it uh versus where you want to think
about uh chilling it up and planning
something else
I'm G to skip the slide and that slide
but basically just showing you the same
relationships as you get into that 55
and above is not so
problematic but what this is might be
what your field will look like in the
spring if you're evaluating your plant
stand and you can see that in this case
the leaves have all burned off and and
you know some years we keep green leaves
throughout the winter but uh just
because leaves have been frosted off
doesn't mean plant is dead have a really
nice technique for determining uh
quickly whether your plants are dead out
there you can dig them up nice to wash
the dirt off clip back uh The Leaf tips
put them in a bag keep it warm and and
usually within 24 hours you can you can
see something emerging if you don't need
by two days then you can be a little bit
wored you can see in this case a nice
little grein shoot starting to emerge
after probably after 24
hours so in summary I think our Optimum
for winter wheat would be to have a
stand in that 20 to
25 plants per square foot uh but stands
between 12 and 15 per square foot or
more than
adequate most years and stands as low as
even five per square foot have yielded
well if feel if conditions are conducive
to tiller
development and you want to consider how
uniform the stand is across the fields
uh certainly you can have big patches
and it's not uncommon to have big
patches where you lose stand and other
parts that be normal um and you may have
to develop a strategy for how to fill in
those patches not a good idea to leave
patch is just a
wheat others have plants and spring
wheat but you can imagine the challenges
of also harvesting two classes of weed
at the same time and so you know you
kind of have to have a strategy in place
as to how you might handle those patches
I think the bag test is really useful
for they a little worried about whether
they their crop made it or not and it's
as simple as going and getting a few
plants taking the dirt off soil off the
plants cutting back the tissue and and
observing any
regrowth um this this fall as I
mentioned previously we planted late the
plants got emerging late and so these
small ceilings are very difficult to
evaluate um they're going to take some
while before they'll start to emerge and
Sh green and I think the message here
would be we'll probably have to be
patient and and see how things get going
once we have the snow mes and
temperatures uh we don't want to dis up
a crop that's that in a week later will
show some real uh grein and vigor and I
think their question that might have
coming our way is the Vernal
vernalization take place in this late
planted material and I think that most
folks that I've talked to would say it's
very unusual that we didn't get enough
inition and and start the germination
process in the fall and maybe even this
spring if that's the case we won't we
won't have enough accumulated cold
weather to do vernalization so I I don't
think that's going to be as big a
concern as whether we actually have an
adequate adequate stand in the spring
so with that uh I think I'm kind of
probably have time for one question if
somebody wants to ask a question then
I'll turn it over
to for the uh topic on WE control and
identification I can't see any hands up
there I think KK turn it
over
thanks Joel good morning
everybody this work in
here Joel and Blake had asked me to come
in and talk a little bit about the wheat
control especially the winter annual
wheed complex and I had opportunity to
stick a few other things in there as
well especially towards the end some of
you may have been involved with the
kosher monitoring the sample collection
ctions that we did over the winter and
I've got some information there relative
to glyphosate as well as the response of
the plant samples to floxy
here I think we you know thinking about
winter wheat and definitely the winter
annual grass complex is causes conations
for all kinds of people TR sheet being a
species that we don't see in North
Dakota very often definitely more of a
Mont 10 a
weed but areas where it is an issue it
definitely
is occurs in enough population to where
it definitely reduces yield and as you
can see the the heads there kind of
describe those as a an open football
shape as opposed to Japanese ver be
looking at a little
bit relatively little pubescence on the
leaf tissue membranous short membran is
Lial
and if we compare that with Japanese bro
Japanese bro does have a very short liil
it has a very
dense mat of hairs along the the sheath
of the leaf as well as airs on Leaf
surface itself on the
blade still fairly small so it's not
easy it's not like yellow fox tail where
you see those very long
straggly hairs at the base of the leaf
blade but it creates a shroud around the
plants so you can see plants kind of
have a Halo up to them or a
gall and as you see this in this next
slide that dense mat very very heavily
pubescent and the amount of pubescence
is related to the temperature regime
that it's been exposed to as well as
some of the environmental conditions
related to moisture so have
very densely pubescent you can have
fairly sparse pubescent but they tend to
be quite long relative to the to
relative to the Downey
BR surface and then with the seat head
there you can see it's more of a compact
football shape the Floric individual
seeds do not open up nearly as much as
as true
sheet but Downey bro is really the the
one that causes us all of our problems
North Dakota it is more difficult to
control with herbicides and is able to
germinate and emerge in the
spring along with Japanese and easily
produ seed talked briefly previously
about vernalization of winter wheat crop
that can have that needs to happen with
these plants as well and and even the
cooler spring temperatures at in the
evenings is enough to initiate seed
production for these plants so just
because it emerges late in the spring
doesn't necessarily you're going to
avoid seed
production this also has a dense sheath
paars but they're quite a bit shorter
and I think the entire field of the
plant has a lot more of a velvety touch
Downey brone tends to be a little bit
more prone to the purple
coloration that's brought on by the C
through the winter and you can see dowy
bro in
wheat The Tint of purple coloration
reddish coloration and then also one of
the seeds with the long on that will
give the dowy Bro inflorescence a much
more feathery appearance as you see on
the right as opposed to the tight
clusters the football shaped thas of the
Japanese bro seed
fls dowy bro like I said before is
definitely more difficult to controll in
Japanese brome and when it establishes
in the fall to wait until the spring it
can create very difficult control
situations it is controlers tends to be
more metal in the fall the plants are
smaller they haven't initiated as many
tillers and there's just not as much
tissue to try to get controlled with the
herbicide control options before the wi
is in the ground of course include
glyphosate which has provided very
exceptional control and we do have two
products LI or prepair that are
registered before wheat and both of
those can provide some suppression I
would not necessarily
expect complete full season
control but they will help reduce the
early season competition so that you
have smaller plants later on with
postemergence
treatment as far as post Emer
then if you have clear field wheat
Beyond is definitely a good option and
I've also found Olympus power Flex to be
very good options for control of these
winter anual PRS
Maverick can provide a very good level
of control however in North Dakota with
our high soy we definitely have issues
with carryover as there probably not a
lot of Maverick used except for areas
where you know that you're going to be
coming back to cereals in The Following
season and then Cera for Everest ribf
fire Max do provide good suppression and
if the plants are small enough will
provide adequate control of Downy broom
and those are strong enough to they
should provide excellent control of the
Japanese
broom foxtail barley is another plant
that's becoming an issue throughout the
state and in the seing stage it is very
small very thin leaves also has puesd
along the leaf sheath but the leaf
blades are a bit narrower and at the
seeding stage is when you really need to
control this because as a perennial once
it truly establishes it is difficult to
control with
anything and when we get to that stage
for the Post emergence treatments
Olympus uh has provided the best
activity can kill some of the plants but
more there we're just trying to prevent
suction for the following seasons and
other products tend to be a little bit
weaker on it power Flex I haven't had
enough experience to know whether it
controls well or
not perley lettuce would be one of the
broadleaf winter annuals look like
dandelion if you turn the leaf over you
have the long row of of spiny growths
off the mid
rib prickle lettuce is a composite
species it is controlled very
effectively
by by many of the growth Regulators but
especially poiry type products such as
ctail CM o White
match horse weed I see
my Z fell down below as they moveed from
one system to the other but horse weed
is comom a larger issue in North Dakota
because of the resistance that has
developed to glyphosate we have
confirmed that in Cass County there are
other areas of L more Pierce and
Macintosh for samples have come in where
we suspect there could be some
resistance C been tested
yet with the without use of glyphosate
really on controlling young rosettes
plant growth regulators and ALS
Inhibitors at those early growth stages
tend to be fairly
effective fi Penny Crest we get into the
on the mustard side of things recognized
by the penny shaped seed pods that
enclose the seeds
it takes off very early in the spring
and ALS Inhibitors are very effective
even once this plant starts to Bol
another couple of other mustard family
Tans and mustard flicks meat and very
finely divided leaves and they're also
control at the early rosette stages is
important for control so that it does
not extend to the stage flowers are
being produced you may still be able to
get control with ALS
Inhibitors especially with with
combination of a phoxy type herbicide
but control definitely starts to get
more
limited comparing this with a perennial
this is false chamomile false chamomile
once it is established as a perennial
again very difficult to control
combinations of ALS products plus a
phoxy have done quite well but a lot of
the herbicides used in cereals that are
based on contact type products will not
be very effective
on this
weed there we see false C meal once it
starts to flower you get that typical
daisy flower head on
it the other thing that I wanted to talk
about for a little bit was the kosher
monitoring we have several fields that
people sent in samples last year this
was initiated because we had two
specific sites one up in Pierce County
and one in the corner of stutzman County
that glyphosate resistance was suspected
in
2011 through Greenhouse testing we did
that both of these locations had very
elevated level of resistance where even
a gallon more than a gallon of Power Max
was not controlling all of the plants
and compared with that with 11 ounces
that would control every plant in the
susceptible check definitely indicated
that we had a
problem the same seed block was
we've treated with Clarity and staran
Ultra trying to identify some of the
other control options that might be
available for cereals and we were not
pleased with the response indicating
here definite survival and very vigorous
growth after full labeled rates of
clarity even in corn or the starting
rate the high use rate 5.7 fluid ounces
was not killing all of the plants
so we had several samples coming in from
around the state mostly from the eastern
half as you can see on the map here we
did have a few Coosa samples coming in
from the Far Western I95
Corridor and these were seated into two
pots in the greenhouse we had a
susceptible check in the upper right
hand corner and resistance check in the
lower leftand corner and spraying these
pot with glyphosate a typical response
and more than 50% of the populations
were controlled easily with that
standard rate of Power Max the Green in
the corner there of course with the or
the resistant check from Pierce
County but we did have several of the
flats that had different amounts of
regrowth depending on if it was a 1x
or essentially a 3X
rate in some of those pots the control
was almost non-existent we also sprayed
all of the with for ox up here and
typical response before Ox appear would
not be complete plant death but these
plants that are very injured however can
start to recover after a couple of weeks
and start to produce growth this is a
serious concern for our late season weed
management because those plant that
remain down to the canopy all season
long once you remove the wheat canopy
they can start to produce new choots and
produce several thousand seeds per plant
even after harvest so on the kosa side
of things what are some of the other
options we do have very effective use of
glyphosate or thox appear still in much
of the state however we do have thox
Pier looking as well as it should from
essentially every area where wece
samples in those areas and cereals of
course will rely on Buck tril with
either peroxyl any kind of
verox CAC product seems to be working
quite well yet in other crops where you
can use atrazine that has been very
effective po Inhibitors the aim is very
effective in crop if the plants again
are less than two inches tall sharpen
Can Be an Effective pre-plant burndown
at it's a moderate use rate however we
cannot expect very much soil residual
from sharpen for managing kosher into
the season essentially it comes down to
making sure that you don't have plants
there when your crop is established and
trying to manage those emerging plants
before they get Beyond about three Ines
in height with with the sweet products
that we have available I know there's a
lot of areas
that are listening are probably no till
or minimum till but cold hard steel is
still probably the most effective and
reliable oan management tool tool
because of the short soil residual of
the seed and the susceptibility of the
plants to
cultivation I believe that might be the
end of my slide set so if you have any
questions you might be able to answer
some on issues or other topics that
might be pressing in your
mind see a couple on there that I
recognize good morning
everybody doesn't look like we have many
questions coming in I will be able to
stick around for a little while so maybe
if you type in questions for me as as
Blake is doing some of his discussion
then before I have to leave I can still
maybe answer
those thanks Joel Kurt and I want to
thank NDSU and particularly Scott for uh
helping coordinate uh the webinar and
and for all support we've had in in the
promotion of it let's
see oops I went back up to one didn't
IO start
over
[Music]
still
oh got be right in
here okay here we go yeah so you can
click on the
name Arrow just one by one all right
thanks let's get started here and try to
move uh rather quickly if I can and what
we're going to talk about a little bit
this morning is a little bit on nitrogen
management and then some on on disease
management some of the research that
we've been doing with NDSU and SDSU and
ourselves if we just look at at that
first slide you're you're taking a look
at there The Soil Test Plus the applied
in and this is over trials be conducted
in North Central Northeast South Dakota
and then through the central range of of
North coot all the way from Crosby to to
Jamestown to Allendale kind of on that
kind of a line and probably about 80 to
100 miles either side of it and what
you'll see there is you you look at the
maximum levels were probably coming
someplace between 180 and 20 120 pounds
of total available and uh if you look at
at John LC's data from North East North
Dakota you'll see that from 2009 to 2011
since John has started working on winter
week you'll see it probably pretty close
to that same amount of nitrogen uh maybe
slightly higher on on the top end uh the
one thing that was was kind of
interesting and when we added the 2012
data into the DU sites we added another
five locations and you'll that that
bottom line is is shifted a little bit
to the left to a little bit less
nitrogen and the reason for that we
believe is if you remember the winter
was open we were warm most of the winter
and then March was about 15 degrees
noral and we think there was probably
quite a bit of extra conversion going on
in the soils from the organic matter and
so we had actually two sites that
responded to end additional end we had
two sites that that showed no response
to additional end once we got to that
per 60 Bush yeld goal plane and then we
had one site
where actually every level of end that
we added decreased yield further and
that was due to the fact that the
additional end caused lodging so the
more end we put on the more lodging we
had and the lower the yields became with
that nitrogen and we we knew that to be
the case uh through Farm experience and
and past yield experiences but in
actually now in the 13 years we've been
doing these trials this is the first
year we've been able to document it in
trial setting and so that that does
happen so if we look at the amount of
nitrogen talking with Ron gelderman
South Dakota State SDSU is still at 2
and a half pounds NDSU is is at still at
2 and a half pounds per bushel axal
nitrogen and uh they're working on new
wrecks some data that we've been using
in our DU studies from ARS that was
conducted for a long period of time
winter weat at Mandan North cord at
Sydney Montana was was 2.25 pounds of M
for bushel for 12% protein we're pretty
comfortable with that we think at some
point in time hopefully with more data
we'll actually be able to reduce that
number further and I think as some of
these new breeding programs and
techniques come online now you'll start
to see groups focus on greater
efficiency with nitrogen as well in
these new Vari one thing I just wanted
to point out I I showed this slide last
year is that we just need to remember
and working with our producers or if you
are prod producer is that winter wheat
has a higher yield potential than the
spring seated Wheats by 20 to 30% so you
need to take that into account when you
design your nitrogen programs for this
spring or if you've already done it last
fall uh the other thing that remember in
that is I think winter week probably can
get by with that quarter pound less per
Bushell than than the spring grains can
so you do gain some efficiencies there
but probably not enough to make up the
fact that you need to add more into to
your wi week to attain those yields
uh one thing is is we talked about the
maximum end needed for for maximum yield
to be in that 180 to 220 230 range
obviously
economics play an impact on that and
what that Final End rate will actually
be and you can see on this slide I'm
going to see if I can make this point at
work over on the left side you've got
four and and $6 wheat so you got two
sets of lines obviously if you got
higher priced wheat you can afford to
put more nitrogen on on uh on the crop
the other thing that you've got is is if
you look on the the far right you've got
50 Cent In which is the blue lines and
the 75 cent which is the green lines
with the $6 we so the cost van is going
to impact where those where that line is
at the other issue that you have is the
in protein discounts or notebook or and
and no protein discounts obviously if
you're you're looking at the where
there's there's no discount on the
protein on the top or the blue we reach
our maximum end level at an earlier
stage but if you have
discounts you you'll notice then that
that you actually need more nitrogen to
to reach your uh top net profit
potential for the winter week so you can
take a look at this slide more and and
as we uh will post these our websites at
NDSU and and du and study these a little
bit but uh they're they're kind of
interesting and someday hope we can can
develop a a table that will allow us to
plug in the discounts plug in the the
cost of the nitrogen the cost and the
price of the wheed and and be able to
predict more closely the amount end that
we should probably be looking at on a
given
year if we look at placement uh Steve
pulled together some data for me uh from
our last two years of of end trials that
incorporate timing as well and you'll
note that there's really no difference
in yield from the seating time
application will replace the end B of
the soil surface to the the surface
applications of 28% with stream bars and
so if you look at it which would be
breaking dormy and then we've got the
combination of seating plus which is the
Ura down uh below the surface at seating
times long with the early stream bar and
then the last one is the seating with
the late stream bar you can see there's
there's less than a bushel difference in
those over the 2-year period and this
follows a very similar pattern to the
number that we generated from 04 to
through 07 in North and South coota in
our
Tri if we look at the proteins this
pattern of the last two years in our end
trials follows that that same time span
in North and South Dakota when we did 04
to8 but that that ball seating
application actually uh does have a
tendency to have a little less protein
than than the spring applic and it
generally runs anywhere from 3/10 all
the way up to 6/10 less uh than the
spring
applications and I I think that that
graph basically tells you to that the
more n you put on the later you put it
on the higher the protein levels will
be just uh one site this year where we
we did see response to the full rate of
nitrogen rates was at Crosby North
Dakota and we had application versus
spring application and then nitrogen
rates as well but if you look at
treatments in two three and four on the
left those were Ura out seating time
placed in a deep band and then N5 six
and seven were stream bars uh N2 was a
60 bushel yield goal rate three was 85
and four was 110 and five six and seven
were corresponding to one thing you'll
note was that there was
probably slightly higher yield to the
fall application with the Ura when you
average those three at
91.5 versus the the stream bar in at
89.5 statistically obviously not
different but we were noticing that
pretty consistently this year we think
that was probably due to the fact that
we had the urita placed below ground we
we did not have we did have excess
moisture obviously following seating and
and during the course of this growing
season and where we looked at the uan
sometimes the rainfall didn't come
following the uan application for
anywhere from two to four weeks
following U applications so there was
some delay in in availability of the the
U and if you look at the proteins on the
right hand side you'll note that with
the ining fertilizer rates within the
n234 and then within the n56 7 you'll
see increasing levels of protein which
you would expect the other thing again
just showing the protein on the right
the average of 11.6% for the Ura in the
ball versus the 12.2% for the uan in the
spring just pointing out to the fact
that some spring nitrogen has the
ability to increase your protein LS for
you then looking at at our watery stage
nitrogen application in other words
applying 10 gallons of 28% with 10
gallons of water for a total of 20
gallons per Acer with a with a flat fan
nozzle uh trying to increase your
proteins right after flow but before the
kernel leaves that watery stage and
hasn't re reached the milk stage but if
you look at the
yields of the uh let me get the pointer
here comparing the the watery stage and
versus the no watery stage and you can
see that the yields were identical in
some cases depending on how the
applications go some people do worry
about the water stage application
reducing yields due to Leaf burn but we
did not have any issue with that the
last two years if you look at the at the
apprach levels on the right side you'll
note that for the 60 Bush yield goal
when you increase those nitrogen levels
for the 85 Bush we increase the amount
of protein from 12.1 to
13.1 and uh you can see that that
similar Trend under the no watery stage
uh nitrogen applications or excuse me
with no actual application at the
lottery stage you can see that the
increased levels of an increas the
protein but I think the important thing
here is if you look at the the yellow
shaded area in the bottom the watery
stage application gave 12.8% potation
versus none at 11.7 for the average so
we picked almost a full point of protein
up this year from that application last
year those numbers were at about a half
percent we look at some some information
that Ron gelderman shared with us in
December and want to thank Ron for these
Ron had done some trials with ESN on Ura
and its influence on on winter week
yield the thing that that I want to
point out as you'll notice these are two
locations Fort pier and wall and you can
see there are some tremendous yields at
at Pier and 102 with the fall
application of your in 107 with the
spring application of your in the thing
that you'll notice though is he added
the ESN they were both 102 and with that
spring application he lost about five
bushels and you'll see that he lost
eight bush with a spring application uh
at wall and my guess is is that this was
100% ESN treated Ura that that ESN that
Ura to a point where it didn't benefit
yield then you noticed in in the next
slide that you'll see that the the
protein levels actually increased a
little bit and that would probably fit
that reasoning then is that the ESN held
that that nitrogen so if you're going to
use ESN with your winter weat uh
application just remember winter week
needs that nitrogen early you're
probably definitely not going to want to
put 100% youra spread out there in the
spring of the year on your winter
we we look at this this next slide
looking at aggain this was some work
that John lukach has done uh up in
Northeast North Dakota he actually had
six sites in in 2010 and 2011 and I I
dropped the one site I was a little
uncomfortable with with the gray the the
URI agotan was had had dropped its yield
pretty substantially I think it's one of
those outlier type situations uh but at
any rate you can you can take a look at
the yields at the various locations for
10 and 11
and you know in in several cases there's
no difference in yield but in two or
three cases there are some some
differences in yield and if you look at
the averages on the far right you can
see the Ura was was basically 80 buels
the Ura plus agane was 83.8 or about 84
and then the ammonium nitrate is not to
have any volatility because it's it's
100% nitrate had
83.3 so it's kind of a check to to the
agrian um as John says it's not meant to
work every year because you hope you're
going to get rain that Ura on the
surface and it's going to take it in and
I agree with John so it's in those
circumstances where maybe like in 2012
we apped the Ura early we had an early
spring we didn't get any rainfall for
two to four weeks so you'd hope expect
to see a response I know on some of the
trials that we did in 2012 we did not
see a response uh to the agine and again
I think it went back to the fact that we
were getting sub of organic matter uh
that we uh it wasn't an issue I think
this is probably the most important
thing I'm going to show in my portion of
the slides today Joel talked about
stands and stage of winter week and if
you look at the the top leftand
picture uh you'll notice that the
development here is is from below the
soul surface all the way up to one Le
stage and this was actually in the1 at
our Min not location at Windfield and
then if you look at the bottom slide on
on the right this was actually a little
foul strip plot area that that hadn't
been seated the prior year we seated
right through those areas you can see we
had two and a half Lea whe there versus
the stage that we had one of the things
that we tell Growers is our goal is is
to have approximately 50 to 70 in per
square foot when we come to that Harvest
stage now obviously if if we're seating
and we're seating at rates of 25 to 35
plants per square foot we're going to
need to make up some time here so we're
going to need to want to encourage some
King and so we're going to want to
probably put some nitrogen on early uh
to enhance
that the chillery prospect so if you
look at the the two pitchers in the two
corners we got good Viger on the field
on the left but we got very poor Vigor
on the field on the right and what you
want to do is just as soon as you can
traffic that field once the frost is out
you probably to get 15 to 25 pounds of
an on some point Ura or or 28% or
whatever form you can get it on and
hopefully get some rain and help
stimulate the
children just thing I'm going to cover
now is just a little bit on on disease
management and mainly it's on on funas
site timing applications and and on
response in 2012 we saw the least
response we've seen in the past three to
four possibly five years uh to fungicide
application as you recall it was dry
early so can spot wasn't a big issue and
scab was not a big issue we did have
some stripe rust in some locations in
the Eastern Dakota uh but you can see
that in our 2012 variety trials which
are scattered across North and South
Dakota we had a 3.8 Bush response across
all varieties that obviously varied from
location to location and from variety to
variety with about a 5% return increase
in yield I should say we looked at 2009
it was a 10.2 bushel response and about
15% increase in yield uh 2010 was a 14.2
bushel with about a 20%
response and 2011 was was a 12.9 or 13
bushel with about a 24%
increase and and so we look at that
average across all those years with 12
included it's been about a 10 bushel
response with about a 15% increase
in John gas and data I'm not going to go
through this slide but I just wanted to
show it to you and you can go back to
again to the websites and dig into this
if you want but this is John's data from
Northeast North Dakota from 9 10 11 and
12 and from that data these next three
or four slides are summarized from that
data but if you look at at the sites
there was 22 experiments that contained
the pasaro application at early flower
in the sto with the herbicide and then
the pasaro at at the early plow and then
the check and you can see that in in
those years in Northeast North Dakota uh
he's getting most of this benefit from
the pasaro application at the year CL so
in three out of 22 experiment
experiments as indicated below he had a
five Bush greater yield increase the
trip herbicide time with the fungicide
so if you look at the next one you you
broke that further apart and he's
indicating that in five out of 14
experiments uh there was a five Bush or
greater yield increase due to the flag
Le Fungicide and then in 12 out of 14
experiments it was due to the early FL
fungicides so for John in that area uh
that is pretty evidence that that
application at that early flower stage
is really important then he went on to
further break out a few other
comparisons and indicating that in four
out of 10 experiments bisaro treatments
yielded five bushels or more than the
fure treatments I think many of you
probably remember Marsh McMullen the
NDSU plant pathologist that retired last
year always indicating that she felt
that the parar will P for the difference
and cost between that and the FK here
and the generics and John's data here is
indicating the same now if you look at
the next statement in seven out of 10
years poer increased yield by five
bushels are greater over the no
fungicide treatment and in the case ofar
it was eight out of 10 experiments in
that particular series I think if if you
look further south say South of Highway
2 and west of Highway uh there you'll
see those early herbicide treatments or
the combination of the herbicide and
fungicide pay more than they do in
John's area because handspot is a bigger
issue as you move into to a different
climate compared to what John has up in
the north east corner of
nor uh just in closing to open it up for
questions uh we're thinking about
conducting a webinar in July or August
again uh to talk about a number of
different things but to prepare
proceeding in the fall U some of the
stuff we'd like to probably share then
is we're getting quite a bit of new data
with with starter trial research with p
and potassium chloride and sulfur and so
we're going to share some of
that
also want to share some information on
some of the noil rotations that are
going on around around the country this
is just a slide from the ccsp farm that
is kind of jointly LED between rers and
Northeast South Dakota and Southeast
North Dakota and what you have there is
a blue lines is the yield for corn you a
corn corn rotation where the corn is
stripped till uh the second bar the rose
colored bar is is a wheat wheat a spring
wheat winter wheat and then corn
following that and if a strict no till
set til and then the third one the elar
is is a spring wheat winter wheat and
then corn but the winter weed is strip
tilled and fall and then the corns
planted into that and then it's a
soybean corn rotation where the soybean
ground of strip till and the corn is
planted into that and you'll just notice
the fouryear average I did not include
2011 because of hail uh but you'll note
that that the uh the strip Heat and the
soybean strip till are both very
competitive one another over the long
term term and you'll note that the corn
on corn even using the strip till uh
cannot compete with those two and then
the other thing you should point out is
actually in 12 and 08 you'll note that
the corn has done a little better in one
year and then that the the noil wheat
without the strip actually done the best
and that's when we're in a drier
environment and warmer environment in
those and I think the one thing we
should remember is we've been in quite a
period of wet years and I'm just kind of
wondering if we're not transitioning
back to drier climate and if we do uh
some of the things and some of the
practices that we look like we may need
to go back and evaluate where we're at
prior to this web period so those are
some of the things we'd like to probably
take a look at the next webinar some of
the rotation impacts on economics and
some of the things dealing with
rotations on leader
resistance I'm going to quit with that
and we're going to open it up to
questions well we're waiting for some
questions again I just remind you that
um we'll be uh posting these to the
websites and if the South Dakota state
folks like us to ship it to them and
have them posted on their website we can
do that as well number of the pieces of
data that that we used in our trial
things are from South Dakota um the
other thing what we did also indicate
that we were going to give out a little
prize and uh Joel picked out a number
for us and uh then Scott figured out who
who the login was and it was Sue raisin
and I believe Sue is the writer for the
farm and ranch guy bismar so Su will be
getting you to that little GI later
on okay I see there's a a comment there
about that there's less than 10% of the
winter weed in our area has emerged what
are the hopes for a decent
CR we can Joel and I both
respond yeah that that really is a a
point of concern
um because we really don't know what the
status of that seed is I mean it it's
quite possible that it imbibed and
started the germination process and that
process will continue as we get into the
spring and uh that seed will obviously
have bur so that's not a critical issue
it's just kind of how much Vigor and how
much stand we're going to likely get
from a a crop that really just started
the process of germination in the fall
so that would be one scenario I guess we
could have a scenario where those seats
sit there dry and never did germinate
they'll germinate in the spring and uh
and then you know I guess in a worst
case scenario they'll they'll act like a
winter wheat crup was planted in Spring
and will not have been vernalized
but my my sense would be that in most
locations we probably had enough uh
moisture to get this germination uh
process started and that we'll have to
keep a close eye on the fields as we
come into spring and to see if they're
survived you know that's one strike
against them being lady
mergers um in small plants in the
fall and
um and hopefully that they'll we'll have
the kind of weather that will allow
those things to express themselves and
get out of the ground before it gets too
late in the season to where we have to
make some kind of determination for
determining the crop and plant something
but I think generally we would say that
that it's not a hopel situation that uh
that uh often we have success when
fields we planning the fall really
didn't emerge completely in the fall but
we're able to get a start and and then
develop into the
spring I just com I've been working with
winter weat since 1977 and you know it
seems like one location every year
either with research or with my actual
Fields Farm as well was
that we would have a location someplace
where witer we either was underneath the
so surface or slightly above the soil
surface um but so much of the WEA it
makes it or not depend on obviously over
winter but this period we're in right
now if we can get some moisture to Reet
that surface if the crown is still alive
anyway uh there's still a very good
chance that this crop will make it I
think we've only lost one research plot
since
1999 uh due to poor emergence and we've
had quite a few of them that were either
below the Sol surface or half Leaf to
Leaf stage of grow uh don't be
completely discouraged by it I guess the
other thing I'd encourage you to
consider is the fact that if you're dry
and you take this crop out what crop are
you going to plant and what crop is that
crop going to have any better chance of
making so I I'd encourage you
particularly in those areas where you
don't have any subsoil moisture to give
this crop a little bit of time before
you get too
anxious
okay okay I just want to one comment if
if you're seeing mold uh on the plants
is probably dead so that is generally a
pretty good sign that that plant has
sued what was the next
question 32 degrees start toow yeah Joel
says 32 degrees so in end I agree with
that as far as vernalization I'm not
worried about vernalization at all if
you've had that seed in the ground my
guess says there's been enough moisture
went for that seed to swell and that uh
that's all it takes then once then it
gets cold again then the vernalization
process is is taken play care
of responded to you were talking before
there yeah and that be the next
question and as far as how long is it
the temperature required to to be cold
again Joel I can't remember what that
time period is you know it's it's
probably about a 30-day
period yeah Joel saying it's about a
30-day period that you need for that
cold one of the things that you can do
is if you go to our website or the DU
Canada website or this is just catch one
there's a Dr fer has winter Cals manual
there and there's a really good section
on cold and vernalization and I would
guess that NDSU and SDSU probably have
that in their materials as well
someplace
and just bear in mind it doesn't have
crazy yeah and Joel pointed out and and
that's true that it doesn't have to be
below freezing for the vernalization to
occur it's just temperature
Circle ser and then Becky actually
answer Aon answered okay so then just
okay next question from Evan is when we
planted into broken
CRP and am most concerned with the
volunteer Gras mostly Timothy what
herbicides would you recommend
[Laughter]
Jo I
think yeah I think unless it's one of
those winter annuals generally the
normal you know grass wheat control will
take out most of grass just want to get
good
timing
start goals goal's response is you know
if it's it's your Ann your winter
annuals or your your annual grasses you
know we've got some tools to select from
with if pral which I think Timothy is
and I'm not familiar with with control
on on Timothy uh but my guess is is is
you probably don't have much choice in
terms of that control but I tell you
what if you want to go to our website
and drop me an email Evan uh I'll do
some research on that and and try to get
back to
you okay we think we may have missed a
question here I'll get to the ice
question here in a couple seconds I
can't remember now was that the first
one you went to yep what about that okay
no that was the first
one and there's the okay where we at so
ice okay ice can have a very detrimental
effect on win uh particularly as we we
get closer to uh breaking dormy is that
plant is is needing more oxygen but uh
if you get get a layer of solid ice over
top of that plant and it stays there for
probably four to seven days uh it can
actually
cause
desiccation and and the most the worst
situation would be is that surface is is
probably a little dry and you get some
melting going on and then you get a
solid layer of of water around that
crown and all the way to the surface of
the soil and that that it becomes
probably the most desal children yeah so
it's it's not what you call typical
winter kill this would be ice en
casement it's very deadly there's
nothing you can do about it I mean it
it'll doesn't take long to kill the
plant but that common except in your low
spots typically that you would have your
whole field covered with ice but it's
yeah it's anytime from now
until uh things get too big to be iced
up uh ice encasement can be a real uh
lethal kind of scenario one of one of
the things we've experienced is is that
if the ground is warm underneath the ice
layer that ice can actually will
actually granu particularly if you've
got a snow layer above the ice and uh
sometimes it it will gruiz fast enough
that that there'll still be enough
oxygen movement or if you've got stubble
sticking through that ice that can also
act as a conduit for oxygen as well and
that can
help well I think we're going to wrap up
um unless we have a quick
question well thank you folks for
attending uh looks like we had pretty
close to 70 folks on and I think there
were some groups in the session so if
you find us effective way to communicate
some timely issues let us know and we'd
also appreciate feedback on the type of
information you'd like to see in these
webinars so thanks again for your
participation thank you very
much